this video is brought to you by sheath
what's up wisecrack michael here to
prove that we are living in the weirdest
and stupidest reality
in the multiverse let me set the stage
for you the year is 2021
a message board that's been on our radar
as the place where dum-dums accidentally
lose fifty thousand dollars on a three
thousand dollar investment
has managed to make hedge fund managers
and the top one percent
lose it on national tv this fair share
is a bush
concept that angry man is billionaire
leon cooperman and he's crying because a
subreddit called wall street bets has
cost his hedge fund friends
billions of dollars primarily through
buying one key stock
gamestop in fact these intrepid
redditors have been on such a buying
frenzy
that they sent gamestop share price
soaring from a little over 18
a month ago to an all-time high of 483
now lots of people have rightly asked
questions about what this means for the
stock market for regulators and
for sad angry billionaires but we think
it's interesting because it poses a
fundamental question
is the stock market what people think it
is so
join me for this wisecrack quick take on
game stunks
and before we continue i want to give a
shout out to this week's sponsor sheath
now if you watch our culture bench
podcast then you may already know that
low quality underwear
is a chap of mine which is why i was
excited when i learned about sheath
sheath boxers are underwear for the
modern man whenever i'm looking for the
perfect boxer i want nice quality
material as well as the ability to keep
things cool downstairs i notoriously run
on the hot side so this is an essential
part of my wardrobe sheath boxers are
built specifically for people like me
sheath boxers have three individual
compartments to keep everything cool and
comfortable
traditional briefs get so hot and it can
ruin a perfectly good day but with
sheath's ergonomic design you won't get
the prolonged contact that leads to the
buildup of heat and sweat
so if you want to be chafe-free and not
have to worry about potential
embarrassment all the time then check
out sheath today if you click the link
in the description or go to sheath
underwear dot com slash wisecrack and
use code
wisecrack at checkout you can get 20 off
that sheath underwear dot com slash
wisecrack can use code wisecrack for 20
off trust me you will thank me for this
life-saving technology
now back to the show and now a very
quick rundown
why are cooper minico so outraged isn't
it
good for wall street when stocks go up
well to simplify things a bit
hedge funds don't only buy stock hoping
it goes up
they also place bets if they think a
stock will go down that's called a short
in reality what investors are doing is
borrowing a share
then selling it for what it's worth at
the time then when it's time to return
the share they go out and buy it back
hopefully at a lower price and pocket
the difference
so if the stock goes down i make a buck
but if it goes
up i lose a buck and this is what hedge
funds like melvin capital were banking
on
these stocks that these companies that
they're like crappy companies
well yeah okay yeah they're terrible
game stock share price plummeting
because
let's be honest gamestop is a brick and
mortar store in the age of the internet
in the middle of a pandemic
and everyone is still mad about their
crappy trade-in policy but when lots of
people short a stock
it gives a weird opportunity for other
people to make money
enter wall street bets realizing there
was so much shorting going on with
gamestonk
this plucky band of predators tried to
create a short squeeze
while that might sound like a new
cocktail it's actually a lot more
delicious because it's made with
billionaire tears
oh yeah essentially as the price of a
stock goes
up all these short sellers need to buy
more stock even at insanely high prices
or worse
your perspective losses are so high on
your short position that your brokerage
firm is saying you've got to close your
position now essentially
bite the bullet buy and return the stock
or get the [ __ ] out
all of this just drives the share price
up even further screwing over even more
short sellers and continuing the cycle
all over again and in the case of hedge
fund melvin capital
they had to borrow nearly three billion
dollars from their fellow plutocrats to
cover their losses
which explains why so much of the one
percent are frothing at the mouth
just a way of attacking wealthy people
god he
really can't help himself of course
beyond cooperman
a lot of establishment players are none
too happy about this
this is populism coming for capitalism
the app robin hood for example has
temporarily stopped users from buying
game stunk and brokerage firms like td
ameritrade have followed suit now
according to robin hood this isn't about
defending the huge investment firms that
they're in business with
it's about the company not having enough
money it would go on to limit trading on
other stocks of interest to reddit like
amc
and now even amd meanwhile our redditors
have gained the attention of the sec in
congress alike but under current sec
guidance it's pretty hard to say
what if any regulations wall street bets
is violated while coordinating a buying
effort to raise the price of a stock
sure seems like a legal market
manipulation as bloomberg's matt levine
explains
and investors aren't being misled here
it's definitely illegal when you lie
about a stock to drive up its price
it's probably not illegal when you buy
times square ads that say
gme go burr but we'll leave that to the
lawyers anyway
how did we get here wisecrack how is it
possible that a subreddit can seemingly
break hedge funds
especially as a global pandemic and
massive unemployment seems to
only make them richer well the answer
isn't complicated it just requires us to
shift our understanding of what the
stock market really is
many people talk about the stock market
as inefficient market
to put it briefly an efficient market is
one where prices are
exactly where they should be based on
lots of people having little bits of
information about different things
an efficient market assumes that human
beings are ultimately rational creatures
who buy and sell things you know
rationally sure we might make a few
mistakes here and there but on average
i'll try to maximize my gains and
minimize my losses for example
think about the marshmallow test given
to kids an experimenter will give me a
marshmallow telling me
that if i wait a whole minute before i
eat it i can get another
given that information and the fact that
i'm not a five-year-old child
the rational choice would be to wait a
whole minute and maximize my
marshmallows
let's go
this is what inefficient market assumes
that given all the relevant information
on average human beings are going to
make
rational choices this means for instance
that they'll also buy and sell
stocks at so-called rational prices
given this assumption it's not
crazy for hedge funds to assume gamestop
share price is going to go down
after all it's pretty smart to assume
that the borders books of video games
is going to fare poorly in a world
dominated by amazon and digital
downloads
but what hedge fund seemingly forgot is
that stock markets
aren't actually as efficient as they
think largely because people really
aren't all that rational as nobel prize
winning economist robert schiller
explains
the idea that people are emotionless
calculating borgs is
patently ridiculous the idea that people
are
so optimizing so calculating
and so ready to update their information
you know that's true of maybe a tiny
fraction of one percent of people but
this is not it's not going to explain
the whole market and this is especially
true when we consider
how many redditors are investing in
gamestop not because they believe it's a
strong
underpriced company but rather because
they feel a sense of moral outrage
against wall street
i think that what you're seeing is um
essentially a push back against the
establishment
but it's not just wall street bets
that's coming in and messing up the
rational market with their means
the big banks hedge funds alternate
asset managers they're
all irrational as well even if they say
they're not
this belief that it's emotions and
people making decisions is quite frankly
not true there's a lot of
pressures and flows in this market that
aren't ruled by human emotion
i mean sure they can program trading
bots and do a lot of math which is a
little more rational than
sipping billionaire tears but there's a
whole field called behavioral economics
dedicated to proving just how
fundamentally irrational our whole
financial system is
for example in traditional economics
there's no reason why the day of the
week should affect how the market
performs the market isn't a human being
working a nine-to-five job looking
forward to the weekend but behavioral
economics
shows us that this isn't true with stock
markets consistently closing higher on
fridays and opening lower on mondays
likewise if i made tens of thousands of
dollars on game stunks a traditional
economist wouldn't think i'd take that
money and put it in a riskier investment
but according to behavioral economists
like richard thaler
that's exactly what i do which is why
i'm putting all of my money
into moviepass guys this is a joke
please don't do this
and in case the dot-com bubble taught
you nothing there's no rational reason
to buy shares in pets.com
when the company pulled in 600k in
revenue but spent 11 million in
advertising but hey at least they made
some sweet ads oh yeah
this is my kind of party and sure
gamestop probably isn't worth the
billions of dollars the market values it
at right now but that's what in a
rational market powered by human
stupidity does
and it's not like the wall street elite
haven't made just as big
if not bigger mistakes these are the
same people who decided to sell and
repackage subprime mortgages in 2008
precipitating one of the largest
financial catastrophes in history you
know that event that essentially doomed
millennials entering the job market to
live
in their parents basement guess at least
we got the big short though
big bank small bank i like to make money
but you might be asking where do we go
from here
is gamestop share price eventually going
to crater most definitely
in the future are we going to see wild
swings in the market powered by wall
street bets
probably but more importantly should we
be upset and this is where i'm not so
sure
if this saga has taught us nothing else
it's that the market isn't this
magical rational entity the finance
industry has told us it is their
fortunes aren't necessarily derived from
being smarter
or harder working than the rest of us
instead the stock market is a lot closer
to a casino powered by
faulty human psychology and the one
percent have been gambling away
sometimes to disastrous results just
because a bunch of redditors are now
playing the game too and
winning doesn't mean we should have
sympathy for the other people at the
table
but what do you think wisecrack is
reddit ruining the fair and honest stock
market
let us know what you think in the
comments a big thanks to all our patrons
for being such a huge support
and sharing that juicy stone gossip with
us in our discord you know who you are
be sure to hit that subscribe button
like you're trying to buy a share of amc
on robinhood and don't forget to ring
that bell
as always thanks for watching
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]